bonjour max orville bonjour maurizio
l'temps bonjour aux auditeurs de
martinique première note le président du
modem martinique le président de la
section martic du parti centriste dirigé
par françois bayroux au centre de toutes
les critiques de nicolas sarkozy on y
reviendra mais d'abord comment
percevez-vous vu d'ici la campagne de
cette primaire de la droite et du centre
est bien de toute manière elle n'est pas
étonnante vous savez que le parti
centriste avait d' extrême réserve
concernant la primaire
bon il y à sept candidats qui déclinent
leurs programmes et les variations de ce
qu'ils ont l'intention de faire
bon nous au modem nous avons choisi de
soutenir un candidat alain juppé que
tout le monde connaît et voilà c'est
tout mais je fais partie prenante de
cette primaire ce qui fait que françois
bayrou est au centre de toutes les
attaques de nicolas sarkozy comment
vivez vous ces attaques régulières
récurrentes et très violente de l'ancien
président contre le chef de file de
votre parti de toute façon nicolas
sarkozy a choisi une posture qui
effectivement d'attaqué françois bayrou
vent debout en fait j'ai envie de dire
que c'est une imposture
pina posture parce que lors des
dernières élections territoriales
régionales le modem lui dei et les
républicains faisait bien souvent liste
commune attaqué françois bayrou en
disant qu'il est de gauche
en oubliant que en 2007 c'est lui
président de la république qui a
accueilli des ministres de gauche et
enfin en 2008 s'est encore nicolas
sarkozy qui a soutenu à pau un dissident
socialiste pour faire battre
françois bayrou dans mon sac j'ai fait
tout cela pardon ça vous affecte non pas
du tout nous savons de toute façon nous
connaissons nicolas sarkozy nous
connaissons ses qualités nous
connaissons ses défauts et nous savons
très bien qu est ce qui nous sépare de
lui et a pas si longtemps que ça
à peu près 160 et l'ue ont signé une
tribune qualifiante françois bayroux
d'opportunistes et sur cette liste de
signataires il y a la martinique est
également plaisir
est ce que vous en pensez vous quittez
un lien avec lui il a pas si longtemps
pour les élections à la ctm et bien
justement je pense que de toute façon
y'a de montplaisir avec qui j'ai
travaillé est un sarkozyste il s'en est
jamais caché il ne sait il sait
pertinemment que max orville et
bayrouiste je ne m'en suis non plus
jamais caché et donc je pense encore une
fois que c'est plus une posture parce
que la carrière politique de yan
monplaisir démontre bien souvent qu il a
eu une souplesse en martinique visait ce
que vous l'avez de parfum par partie et
bien qu'il a toujours privilégié
privilégier le dit il l'intérêt national
martinique est bon aujourd'hui si je ne
m'abuse il est associé alfred marie
jeanne indépendantiste bon hier il était
avec oz ont osé bon il un parcours qui
montre que de toute façon il fait des
choix qui montre qu'il n'est pas aussi
j'ai envie d'air fermé que ce que cela
semble être
il ya deux noms plaisir aurait dû
réfléchir avant de signer selon moi je
n'ai pas à commander reja donner des
conseils à vienne montplaisir il est
suffisamment grand pour le faire tout ce
que je vois c'est que cette année lui
sarkozyste et parfois nous avons pu
travailler parfaitement ensemble à un
moment donné et c'est pour cela cause de
cette tension plus que perceptible que
vous aviez pris congé de ba payant
chance non j'ai expliqué très bien dans
la tribune de septembre les raisons pour
lesquelles nous nous étions retirer il
ne revient pas dire of dû revenir
yan monplaisir qui serait candidat dans
dans le nord si ça se confirme vous
pourriez l'encourager le soutenir les
dés pour l'instant je suis président
d'une formation politique centriste qui
participera également aux élections
législatives donc vous me permettrait de
soutenir d'abord les candidats du modem
comment vous êtes convaincus par ce qui
se fait par les soutiens de ces
candidats à la primaire du droite de la
droite et du centre en martinique vous
sentez cette campagne très active comme
on peut le voir par exemple dans
l'hexagone en tout cas le comité juppé
auquel j'appartiens mène des actions de
terrain régulièrement même des
conférences forte intéressante
je crois que chaque terrain tellement
visible ça me passe complètement
inaperçue disons que peut-être ici c'est
un écho légèrement différent et
justement tout le travail est de faire
savoir à l'électeur martiniquais qu'il a
une possibilité de choisir dès lors
qu'il se revendique de la droite ou du
centre de choisir le candidat qui sera
le mieux à même de pouvoir porter ma
démarche d'éducation plus se focaliser
sur 7,7
cette tension entre le mouvement
indépendantiste martiniquais le parti
progressiste martiniquais haïti voulait
le gras semble être bâtie en chance et
puis ensemble pour une martinique
nouvelle
oui je comprends c'est assez réducteur
au demeurant
parce que de toute manière rien ne
pourra se faire de toute façon sans la
france
les grandes décisions se prennent à
paris ici il ya un travail considérable
à faire au niveau de la ctm
cela va faire bientôt un an que lens ont
vaincu sont en place je suis sur ma faim
je le dis je suis sur ma faim le chômage
ne me semble pas diminuer le chômage des
jeunes non plus dans le domaine
d'éducation l'échec scolaire est
toujours pas tant au niveau du tourisme
je l' ai déjà dit il y a encore beaucoup
à faire le budget alloué que l'équipe de
faire un inventaire a bien écouté sur
une mandature un an d'inventaire cela
signifierait donc qu'il n'était pas
préparé à prendre le pouvoir je ne peux
pas le croire
ayant fait la campagne du premier tour
je suis convaincu qu'il n'y avait des
projets et je demande donc
solennellement à tous de travailler
enfin je l' ai déjà dit je dénonce un
petit peu le fonctionnement de cette
assemblée qui me paraît comment
dirais-je un petit peu mis sous tutelle
alors que selon notre conception là
l'assemblée de martinique devrait
innover faire des propositions or
aujourd'hui j'ai l'impression que c'est
une chambre d'enregistrement
c'est dans ce qu'ils pensent que claude
lise devrait s'affirmer davantage auprès
de monsieur alfred marie jeanne
je ne parle pas des personnes je dis
encore une fois que la ce en ridant de
l'assemblée n'a soufflé le la président
de l'assemblée le président de
l'assemblée de la martinique est
l'incarnation d'une assemblée cette
assemblée doit se prendre en main doit
innover doit faire des propositions à
l'exécutif qui comme son nom l'indiqué
doit exécuter les propositions fait la
soirée à sao s'imposer davantage
ensemble et à mon avis doit
effectivement s'imposer davantage
est ce que le président de l'assemblée à
la personnalité qu'il faut aujourd'hui
contre celle du président du conseil de
l'exécutif pour pouvoir faire cela
mais encore une fois vous voulez à tout
prix m'emmener sur un débat de personnes
moi je vous dis que l'assemblée doit se
prendre en main et s'affirmer davantage
il doit y avoir une collaboration entre
les deux exécutifs
si je ne m'abuse moi j'étais très à
l'aise le modem ne nous avions prévu que
une collectivité unique il fait il
faudrait s'y préparent et voilà les
raisons pour lesquelles nous n'étions
pas les traits on a pris le temps et
pourtant on a pris le temps et vous
voyez alors donc et 18 heures dans la
salle et le président de la région mais
oui peut-être mais ça arrive mais ça ça
fait encore partie des de l'histoire
enfin il ya des choses comme ça qui
dysfonctionne le modem ne pèse pas si
lourd que cela aujourd'hui max orville
vous avez l'attention d'autres actifs
pour les prochaines législatives du mois
de juin
aujourd'hui votre allée est votre allié
naturel en martinique ce serait qui lui
dit aujourd'hui le modem alors je
voudrais toujours qu'on remette un petit
peu les choses rapidement dans le
contexte le modem a à peu près sept ans
de l'existence en martinique ce qui est
très peu pour un petit parti à quelques
élus municipaux j'en fais partie le
modem a participé à toutes les dernières
élections où seul ou accompagné
nous nous travaillons pour faire
connaître notre message depuis un an
nous reconstituons nos forces nous nous
implantons un petit peu dans tout sur
toutes les communes de la martinique et
vous verrez que nous avons des candidats
et qu'ils seront parfaitement au clair
et vous proposeront un programme tout à
fait crédible est susceptible d'être une
alternative crédible
vous avez vous rapprocher de lui payer
avec un philippe petit le moment viendra
de toute façon nous souhaitons que le
centre apparaissent unis s'il est une
île et fort si les diviser on est
effectivement plus faibles et nous
sommes ouverts à tout dialogue fermement
mais sûrement max orville demain la
planète entière aura les yeux tournés
vers les états unis
united states of of america
vous avez un regard forcément sur ce qui
va se passer demain soir hillary clinton
monsieur trompe vous avez une préférence
alors d'abord je voudrais saluer ce
grand moment d'histoire auxquels nous
avons participé que nous avons vu en
direct ça a été les huit ans de barack
obama premier noir américain il faut le
signaler il n'a peut-être pas tout
réussi mais ce fut un symbole fort et je
salue cette personnalité démocrate
quant à demain et bien effectivement
nous suivrons avec attention cette
élection notent nos faveurs vont bien
évidemment sur hillary clinton démocrate
une femme c'est aussi une première nous
ne croyons pas du tout dans le candidat
républicain et d'eau pensons que de
toute manière
à force de d'activer les sentiments les
passions les plus vils et bien ça ne
pourrait pas aller très longtemps merci
d'avoir été avec nous ce matin max
orville merci le président du modem
martinique bonne journée